first time he became a millionaire we
celebrated when I became a millionaire
we celebrated when um you know we bought
our first Supercar we drove that home
from the dealership together but if you
want to take all the good moments from
having a relationship a brotherly
relationship like me and Andrew have and
then he becomes the world's most Googled
man one of the most influential men I
guess in in the world and by default
he's attacked by The Matrix in a way
that and ends up with him being thrown
in prison I feel like I'd be more mad if
I didn't go to prison with him I'd feel
like you know I've taken all the good
from being associated with Andrew and
you know he builds me up and I build him
up and for him to be sitting in jail
without me it would just feel wrong so
I'm not even mad about it I'm the
opposite of mad about it I'm glad they
broke me and I'm glad they said Guilty
By Association I'm glad they throw me in
jail with them and if they frame him for
real and send him back they better send
me back too or I'll break myself in
thank you thank you so much I'll break
into the gym right you know